you have some big news over there with
the uh prince philip in your
neck of the woods in uk did you want to
you need to fill us in on what's going
on with this
well uh as you know i think everyone has
uh
seen the news that he was a buddy okay
yesterday and see it is really you know
his life and everything around him
uh is full of lessons and
just maybe again because of time let us
focus on some of the key lesson
you know uh if i did not watch the whole
funeral services that
was carried out yesterday but it was a
lie you know
state of art and everyone was moving
in a particular way of course they did
not have a big gathering they did not
have
they did not have a big gathering
because of the
covet 19 restrictions and they want to
set
an example a role model which is really
good and amazing
but see prince philip how long did he
live
for almost a century actually according
to the hijra calendar he lived for
102 or three years
this is amazing amazing
and uh but one
lesson how long are you going to live
yeah more than that no one lived more
than that
at the end you will die
as simple as this this is the reality of
this life
and my point is i was i saw
very few pictures of the queen of
the other princess and and are they
thinking about their future when they
are going to
walk in the funeral when other people
will walk in their uh janaza or funeral
now forget about them what about us as
muslims
are we reflecting upon this or people
are thinking that they are going to live
forever
see i'm sure he was observing the best
equality of life because he's like a
king
yeah and one of the very richest uh
families
and uh and he was also looking after his
health
because it is impossible that you live
for this long
life and without taking care of your
health
yeah uh you name it and he was one of
he lived with the queen for they said 70
something 73 years
yeah so he'd been living this as like a
king for
73 years and he had everything he wanted
yeah just like this
he's gone finished so the second lesson
which is now are we
preparing for this moment i would like
non-muslims and heedless muslims in
particular
to think about this i would like to say
that
death is not the end of a human being's
this is a misconception
that people think that once they die
they
are finished no once you are there
once you as a human being once
you are living you will not come to an
end you will be living forever
do you know this reality do we are we
reflecting
upon this reality that we will be living
forever
the point is and instead of living in
america
we will be living in another country
and the rules for that country are
different
from the rules in america or in the uk
or the rules uh prince philip was
living they are different from the rules
he
is now living he is living now
in another abode so
this is another lesson that we need to
reflect upon
especially non-muslims especially
heedless muslims what are the rules
that are there okay you claim
that you are not going to to
uh you are still living you are not
going to finish
so what are the new rules and
regulations in the new country that i'm
going to
live in this is something that we need
to think of
also subhanallah brother
[Music]
death is the biggest challenge i call it
the biggest
challenge for human beings for liberals
for feminists for all these
kind of uh ideologies
because for liberals for example
you ask them yeah okay you want to live
a liberal life okay fair enough
tell me what will happen to me after i
die they say we don't care
i said come on this is the most worrying
thing
it is the biggest challenge see i
haven't mentioned
verses from the quran but even if we
want to mention verses
run away from death if you are truthful
yeah
if you are sincere and truthful and you
have power etc
then protect yourself from death you
won't be able to do that
okay so now tell me
if i live as a liberal person
then what will happen to me after death
now if i live a liberal as a liberal
person am i going to be safe from death
no no no even other methodologies
the only system or the only way of life
that provides you
with the correct answers to live by
is what is islam because
islam is telling you yes
the righteous people will go to paradise
the
evil people will go to hell fire and
they will
get this on the day of resurrection
very simple so
islam provides us with all the answers
the key answers related to this big
challenge which is death
young people old people healthy people
uh
kings queens prince philip later on
uh the queen elizabeth
all of them will die yes or no yeah
pharaoh dying before that everyone died
before that and where are they
any sane person will be busy
to think day and night with this
question this is just
a very simple uh message you know
about the the death of course there are
so many things to
to to learn but some of them are like
you know
not useful to be mentioned in this
blessed month
some great gems from the death of prince
philip that we can take with us
there's a lot of common sense things you
mentioned but it's a shame that common
sense is not always common practice
and the main thing that we can go ahead
and
remind ourselves that it's not yolo it's
not you only live once so enjoy no you
made that fact
you know you hit home that you live in
this life and what you do in this life
to determine
your abode in the next either paradise
or the hellfire my god almighty allah
help us to get to the everlasting bliss
in jannah inshallah